السلام علي الس عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان
لا اله
الا الله
اشهد ان
محمد رسول
الله اشهد
ان
محمدا رسول الله
ا حي على الصلاه
[Silence]
حي على
الصلاه حي على الفلاح
[Silence]
ا حي على الفلاح
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر لا
لا اله
الا
الله بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله
الحمد لله نحمده ونستعين ونستغفره ونعوذ
بالله من انفسنا ومن سيئات اعمالنا من
يهده الله فلا مضل له ومن يضلل فلا هادي
له واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك
له واشهد ان محمدا صلى الله عليه وسلم عده
ورسوله قال الله تعالى في القران المجيد
ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق تقاته ولا
تموتن الا
وتم
مسلمون وقال الله تعالى في القران المجيد
واتقوا الله الذي تساءلون به والارحام
ان الله كان عليكم
رقيبا وقال الله تعالى في القران المجيد
اتقوا الله وقوا قولا سديدا يصلح لكم
اعمالكم ويغفر لكم ذنوبكم ومن يطع الله
ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا
عظيما ان اصدق الحديث كتاب الله واحسن
الحديدي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم وشر
الامور محدثاتها وكل محدثه بدعه وكل بعه
ضلاله وكل ضلاله في النار بعد
[Silence]
الله
‏alight as
beever
obeng
ached of and gu
gu
event come
ابو حرير رضي الله عنه عن ابي حريره رضي
الله عن عن النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم قال
من اغتسل ثم اتى الجمعه فصلى ما قدر له ثم
انصت حتى يفرغ من خطبته ثم يصلي معه غفر
له ما بينه وبين الجمعه الاخرى وفضل ثلاثه
ايام
[Silence]
‏days
‏mery
even dat
[Silence]
الله عليه
وسلم الله عليه وسلم ا الناسب الى الله
واستغفروا فاني اتوب الى الله في اليوم
مره الله
[Silence]
الله عليه وسلم نبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم re
[Silence]
‏some
‏feel
meak
inty sin
asof something
‏deserve for
[Silence]
قل يا عبادي الذين اسرفوا على انفسهم لا
تقنطوا من رحمه
الله ان الله يغفر الذنوب جميعا انه هو
الغفور الرحيم
[Silence]
‏exit of those crossed b those crossed
do to over
‏differ sins and
ma
sin exceeding limits of
souls and be that's means exceed limit
of souls and says even for those
exceeded limit of soul those
are not hope incy not
hope so ask for his repentance no how is
no matter how is ask for his forgiveness
‏take
[Silence]
‏there
‏one comm one and after was now
قال ربنا ظلمنا انفسنا وان لم تفر لنا
وترحمنا لنكون من
[Silence]
الخسرين البقره فتل ادم من ربه كلمات فتاب
عليه انه هوب اليم
[Silence]
‏ex
ex anybody
can
sin that
do
you how
life take ex
[Silence]
‏and att from
‏ag and that
also the wor possible
‏arue among themselves they would ar
among themselves tring groups car
because they to scared of at
times
was one was
[Silence]
للذين امنوا ان تخشع قلوبهم لذكر الله وما
نزل من الحق ولا يكونوا كالذين اوتوا
الكتاب من قبل فطال عليهم الامد فقست قلوب
وثير منهم
[Silence]
فسون يا
علىق
[Silence]
‏could انا اسع بالل في المعاصي وقوم من
المسلمين ها يخوفوني وما ارى الله سقني
اليهم الا ارتدع اللهم اني ق قد تبت اليك
وجعلت توبتي مجاوره البيت الحرام
[Silence]
الحمر
الحميل
highe
was was another another canar from is
‏put later what does that
meat means that you know commit sin and
it means that you are now self aware
there are two stances here one there are
those group of people who are still
blinded by their they still committing
sin they blinded they don't know how big
of a sin they are they don't know that
they sinting and another group of people
are those that are self-aware those
group of people who know they sining who
know and
still unaware
‏those are
people
among those people who and think you
know what
i'll this far in any a place
now all
[Silence]
الله اقول قولي هذا واستغفر الله لي ولكم
سئر المسلمين فاستغفروه انه هو الغفور
الرحيم بسم الله الحمدله واللاه واللام
على رسول صل الله عليه وسم
[Silence]
عدي انف ال
‏all
‏i not
[Silence]
have و
الى الله جميعا ا المؤمنون لكم
تفلحون
الله
are those how done
anding الله ومن لم يتب فولك هم الظالمون
[Silence]
ي للذين امنوا ان تشع قلوبهم لذكر الله
وما نل من الحق
[Silence]
يا ايها الذين امنوا توبوا الى الله توبه
نسوح عس ربكم ان يكفر عنكم سيئاتكم
ويدخلكم جنات تجري من تحتها الانهار
[Silence]
ربنا ظلمنا انفسنا وم تغفر لنا وترحمنا
لنكونن
من we wrong our and if you do not for us
and mercy upon us we be
among do
not what would you
[Silence]
‏could
‏ex upon
us far short
being
andold anything we have eyes to things
to things we have ears to listen to
things we have
things ask
‏think dis
guy
own that
those
mercy
merc ang w
[Silence]
الغف
ح الرحمن
وتوبوا الى الله جميعا ايها المؤمنون لكم
تفح us
[Silence]
ال رسول الله اقول ما تسمعون واستغفر الله
لي ولكم من كل ذنب فاستغفر انه الغفور
الرحيم هذا وصلوا وسلموا على نبيكم كما
امركم بذلك ربكم فقال ان الله وملائكته
يصلون على النبي يا ايها الذين امنوا صلوا
عليه وسلموا تسليما اللهم صل على محمد
وعلى ال محمد كما صليت على ابراهيم وعلى
ال ابراهيم انك حميد مجيد اللهم بارك على
محمد وعلى ال محمد كما باركت على ابراهيم
وعلى ال ابراهيم انك حميد مجيد ربنا اتنا
في الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره حسنه وقنا عذاب
النار ربنا لا تؤاخذنا ان نسينا او اخطانا
ربنا ولا تحمل علينا اصرا كما حملته على
الذين من قبلنا ربنا ولا تحملنا ما لا
طاقه لنا به واعف عنا واغفر لنا وارحمنا
انت مولانا فانصرنا على القوم الكافرين
ربنا لا تزغ قلوبنا بعد اذ هديتنا وهب لنا
من لدنك رحمه انك انت الوهاب ربنا ظلمنا
انفسنا وان لم تغفر لنا وترحمنا لنكونن من
الخاسرين ربنا ارحمهم كما ربونا صغارا
ربنا ارحمهم كما ربونا صغارا ربنا ارحمهم
كما ربونا صغارا اللهم اهدنا في من هديت
وعافنا في من عافيت وتولنا في من توليت
وبارك لنا فيما اعطيت وقنا شر ما قضيت انك
تقضي ولا يقضى عليك انه لا يذل من واليت
تباركت ربنا وتعاليت اللهم انا نسالك من
الخير كله عاجله واجله ما علمنا منه وما
لم نعلم ونعوذ بك من الشر كله عاجله واجله
ما علمنا منه وما لم نعلم اللهم انا نسالك
من خير ما سالك عبدك ونبيك ونعوذ بك من شر
ما عاذ به عبدك ونبيك اللهم انا نسالك
الجنه وما قرب اليها من قول او عمل ونعوذ
بك من النار وما قرب اليها من قول او عمل
ونسالك ان تجعل كل قضاء قضيته لنا خيرا
عباد الله ان الله يامر بالعدل والاحسان
وايتاء ذ القربى وينهى عن الفحشاء والمنكر
والبغي يكم لعلكم تذكرون اذكروا الله
العظيم يذكركم واشكروه يزدكم واستغفروه
يغفر لكم واتقوه يجعل لكم من امركم مخرجا
واقم
الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان
لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان
محمدا رسول
الله حي على الصلاه حي على
الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد قامت
الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر
لا لا اله الا
الله
استدل شاء
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
ين
امين سبح اسم ربك الاعلى الذي خلق فسوى
والذي قدر فهدى
والذي اخرج المرعى فجعله
غثاء
اهوى سنقرئك فلا تنسى
الا ما شاء
الله انه يعلم الجهر وما يخفى ونيسرك
لليسرى فذكر ان نفعت الذكرى سيذكر من يخشى
ويتجنبها
الاشقى الذي يصل
النار
الكبرى ثم لا يموت فيها لا يحيى قد افلح
من تزكى وذكر اسم ربه
فصلى بل تؤثرون الحياه الدنيا والاخره خير
وابقى ان هذا لفي الصحف
الاولى صحف
ابراهيم
وموسى الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله
رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
والضحى والليل اذا سجا ما ودعك ربك وما
قلى ولا الاخره خير لك من الاولى ولسوف
يعطيك ربك فترضى الم يجدك
يتيما فاوى ووجدك
ضالا فهدى ووجدك
عائلا فاغنى فاما اليتيم فلا تقهر واما
السائل فلا تنهر
واما بنعمه ربك
فحدث الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
السلام
first there opp that so pleas take the
to put name up there you want take
[Silence]
‏take
‏rading
don
don st of
trans st taes transf to the academy and
that us
toar and by
thear being as we so those thaty لام